can't ask me to do the kind of a simple
kind of explain what the heck we
integrated assessment modelers who to a
large extent are economists often times
trying to kind of fill in a little bit
on the science doing and what are we
going to do with all the stuff why is
this conversation even necessary so I'm
going to try and tell you about that so
how do I am to represent climate
sensitivity why why do we have these
integrated models and why integration
for uncertainty so I just want to go a
few through a few little things on that
so how do i am represent climate on
sensitive sensitivity ims are really a
very diverse very diverse in terms of
climate representation I kind of go
through these three broad classes there
are simple equations that capture the
global average response to forcing over
a decade of time bills dice model the
merge model fund page of that sort of
character so you know very simple
representations there are the energy
balance models you've heard people talk
about them you know often wigglies
magics engine framework as part of some
of these the G cam model at the
University Maryland P&L for example uses
that and then our program is an
integrated assessment modeling component
we have a full atmosphere ocean general
circulation models although we coarsely
resolve it so it is dealing with all
these things there climate sensitivity
is not really a parameter we put in it's
a it's a it's a result that comes out
although we can we do tune it to
represent many different climate models
to represent uncertainty so we tune it
through the cloud feedback so and and so
there are in the in the IPCC literature
now and broad lature these idea of Earth
system models of intermediate complexity
so the earth system component of our
integrated assessment model is really
very strongly in that class and but
we've linked it to the economic model so
that's the that's the
so that what makes it an integrated
assessment model so each of these three
classes are very different and people
are here can correct me if I'm wrong but
just to kind of give those who aren't
involved in the community you know civil
equation between concentration and
temperature with some lag structure to
account for ocean inertia something like
a three box carbon cycle model you know
magic sand general mechanism energy
balance upwelling diffusion of the ocean
a box model of carbon and then we
represent or email Class C ABC full
representation of many mechanistic
processes land ocean clouds carbon
cycles that treat vegetation response to
carbon nitrogen biology but coarsely
resolved oftentimes we've been using a
2d version so it's resolved latitudinal
II but not longitudinally and vertically
Peter stone I think was one of the he
took the gifts model and turned it into
this 2d thing showing it its land ocean
resolving so even though there's a
latitudinal band we kind of separate
that land into that latitudinal bandit
of that part which is land in that
purchase which is ocean as i said before
climate sensitive an emergent result not
a single cent parameter but sensitivity
can be tuned through the cloud feedback
so there are some different things and i
think one of the discussions that would
brought up earlier is it i'm kind of
puzzling a little bit through is we have
these different measures of climate
sensitivity transient sensitivity
equilibrium sensitivity and then i guess
something that we heard was equilibrium
sensitivity but not really well that's a
Dipity so one of the questions i raised
and we have some of these comparisons as
everyone comparing the same thing as the
same transit sensitivity the same
transient 72 tivity or was different
period so that adds a little bit
confusion of my process and then we had
a presentation just at MIT that claimed
that sensitivity was not a confident
that actually changes with time and i
think this may relate to you know the
nature of what's what whether what we're
talking what we really mean by
sensitivity
so what are the objectives of the
climate model components of these im's
well we're representing the broad time
evolution of climate and all can tune to
specific GCMs to represent and tune to
history I mean I guess we heard this
last debate about how awful tuning class
I wait you know these models
specifically tuned on purpose to kind of
try to be realistic and try to represent
them so they're not typically
representing these processes in any way
that that that we think they would
actually predict them they're trying to
be a response surface fit to the more
complex model or something so they're
intentionally tuned you know the more
process uyen models can relate climate
sensitive physical processes but still
would depend on comparing tuning to more
complex models in the ease of tuning
climate sensitivity or ocean heat uptake
or aerosol thing whereas all feedback
allows the study of effects of the range
of these climate sensitivities so I mean
I think that Chris forest had worked
with us and we use a lot of his work in
our uncertainty analysis there we you
know that does allow us to kind of
evaluate these the properties from data
and actually kind of fit these joint
distributions to history to kind of
understand what the likely value of
these of these parameters are and also
what the range of possibilities are and
we do then I mean we and our group have
the full three-dimensional GCM the full
very complex ocean models and so we're
often times running those and trying to
kind of fit our simpler model to make
sure it behaves reasonably in that
regard some of the limits you know the
class a type has no natural variability
global mean only class b no natural
variability some process global mean
only but then the magic model has a sin
Jen process which takes the global
temperature result and and different
patterns from the archived seem it
models and scales them up and down so
for people that want to use that to do
impact work you can kind of take all the
different pattern scales and scale it up
and down with the with the global mean
temperature so then you get the types of
if you look at doing impact analysis the
type of variation and things that the 3d
of highly resolve 3d GCM would give you
as a part of the range of uncertainty I
guess you would get with any single
temperature I think the simpler models
you know in their impact in their damage
function estimates will look at a range
of different detailed impact models that
have taken different climate scenarios
from different models and estimated the
impacts and that has to feed into their
estimate of uncertainty at some level
although I think what we talked about
earlier the impact work they're just
really has not been a lot of impact work
and a lot of consistent impact work and
a lot of impact work done consistently
across the wide range of scenario so
oftentimes there's not much out there it
may look like we're quite certain about
it but if there's only two estimates you
so uncertain so I think that's it that's
a challenge you know this class-c I me
where we have natural variability 20
minute resolution detailed process but
in this sort of thing there's no real
precipitation events it's just a
constant light mist because it's raining
somewhere around that latitude band
every anytime though then we would we do
the same thing as a send Jenn sort of
thing if we want to get regional things
we can take the pattern scales for the
GCMs and use the latitudinal band sorts
of things to scale that we're still
concerned that that doesn't really give
enough precipitation so we actually can
take the the cam model and run the cam
three-dimensional atmosphere with a kind
of a ocean specifying ocean sea surface
temperatures from other runs we do with
our human model it's a drip down quicker
run of the version but
gets get some of that so that's that's
what some of these are doing and this
and this and this variability you know
is really I think the critical thing and
impacts I mean we talk about extreme
outcomes of climate like six or eight
degrees but the variability sort of
story is a really important one and I
don't know that any of the impact work
has really done a very good job of that
because as we heard the GCMs don't
predict temperature very well so if
you're not predicting temperature for a
region within two to five degrees then
you're not going to predict crop yields
in that region very well today I mean
you have to do much much better than
that and so all the impact work takes
the deltas and it from a GCM and applies
that to some real climate data like 30
year history and moves it up or down but
then it's oftentimes not taking the
second moments of those changes so
variability is changing its not included
so there's a real gap there in terms of
moving there so I think the impact work
is you know is the weakest and I think
it just has not had the funding it
deserves so why integrated models you
know because the answer is we are
looking for depend partly on the
economic component and partly on the
climate component it's not easy to
decompose them so if one is affecting
the other then we can't really we have
to do both at the same time so I have
just a couple of example examples you
know I'm almost embarrassed by the first
one cuz I like Andrew this little bit
and it's all Wiggly but that's okay and
so the optimal abatement level so the
type of model that bill uses the dice
model is really developed to kind of say
we were trying to trade off mitigation
costs and damage costs and as economists
we would like to equate the marginal
damage with the marginal cost and so we
have to assess both the same time in
order to understand where those where
those two things intersect and then I'll
take an example from our our
effort to kind of just think about the
land climate economy feedback so this is
the very simplest sort of something we
might think of as an upward sloping
marginal abatement curve with the level
of emissions abatement here so the more
we abate the higher the marginal cost
you can think of this is a carbon price
it rises we think that the if we don't
abate at all the marginal damage might
actually be quite high this might
intersect here somewhere maybe at a very
high number and so we're looking for
this point so you know we really can't
assess that without doing both the same
time so that's so of course these are
very chron these is just simple kind of
supply and demand curves this marginal
damage curve is some complex connection
between the missions abatement over the
next two or three hundred years damages
over many over lots of time discounted
back to the present the marginal
abatement cost is some you know
optimized timing of abatement over the
next century so these models put that
together and try to solve for that issue
that point so that's the so that's one
reason why we want to understand that of
course if this is these are all
uncertain then we want to handle to
actually ask about the uncertainty as
well for the land climate economy
feedback so our program that we've doing
some of the damage estimates we we have
very comprehensively you know we're kind
of we've tried to remain quite
physically based in these so we try to
take the actual climate scenario ask how
it's affecting plant productivity how
that feeds into changes in crop yield
then we have a food sector in our
economic model so a production sector or
foods you know for agriculture
production sector a food sector so crop
yields go down as a result there's
markets and trading that happen you know
prices go up ultimately consumers a
little less maybe or we use a lot of
other or we use other inputs from the
other parts of the economy to make up
for that proto
tivity loss in agriculture we use more
land so that results in less goods and
the rest of the economies of that
results in a loss to the economy so
we're treating that very so we do some
of that but I'd say that we've been
since we wanted to do each of those
sectors very well we've not tried to
come up with all the sectors we've tried
to do one at a time and kind of
understand what those complex
interactions look like so here isn't it
so this is an example i think the land
climate economy feedbacks are one of
those where this idea of why things need
to be integrated together is very clear
so you know we start with this model of
our economy it's a global general
equilibrium model that has energy and
agricultural markets and Israel all
markets in the economy represented at
some level of detail lots of energy
sectors you know energy-intensive
sectors households consumption trade
amongst regions etc we know that that
economy produces some GHG and other
pollutants no such as energy and
agricultural land you submissions now if
you were doing this a separate thing
this is working group 3 of the IPCC
coming up with these emission scenarios
and then giving them to work in Group
one right so that so that would so you
could see doing this as a separate sort
of phase that would go into some some
version of a couple dosha net if your
model linked to land which has
biophysical feedbacks hydrological
changes radiated balanced rain facts
related to the land cover you know out
of this we are getting changes in solar
temperature precipitation solar
radiation co2 tropospheric ozone
nitrogen deposition so these are the
sorts of things that working group one
might produce and now give to working
group two so that might go into some
sort of an hour version if the
terrestrial ecosystem model could be we
have a very generic crop in as part of
that so it's a terrestrial ecosystem and
agro ecosystem model out of that so
that's this land version so
out of that we get changes in crop past
your bioenergy force productivity so
this might be working group to telling
what group three how some of these
things are going to change so this
change in bioenergy well gee whiz what's
that going to do if bioenergy is a part
of the production sector then all of a
sudden if its costs rise then maybe we
have more co2 emissions so the co2
emission scenario is an independent of
of what we're doing there all that
changes in crop productivity could
change how we use land which is
ultimately going to go back and effect
where we grow crops the temperatures can
affect where we grow crops how much we
grow how much land we need and that's
going to go back and effect CH 4 n 2 O
net co2 from land juice WG two so you
see that these things are all happening
so we want to connect them we understand
if we're going to predict climate here
and if we just take an emission scenario
predict climate predict these impacts
then we're not going to get it right
because these impacts going to be
affecting the missions the land use
change is going to be affecting
emissions and feedbacks and that fell
affecting the climate so that's the note
HR we have population is in there yes
yeah the population is growing the
economy is growing for other reasons
population productivity etc so why
integration for uncertainty this is some
work we did I think was published in
2009 where we take this whole system in
and look at the uncertainty and so what
we have here is full uncertainty with
all the parameters we use that's the
blue curve uncertainty in just the
climate system that's the green curve
and emissions uncertainty and and just
due to admissions uncertainty
uncertainty in the in the economy and
kind of the end
trusting story is here is that if you
didn't have the red one there you'd say
oh gee whiz climate uncertainty can
almost explain all of the uncertainty we
have in the system if you didn't have
the green one there you'd say oh the
missions uncertainty can explain almost
all the uncertainty and so what's going
on well obviously these interact and so
there is this kind of some-some when you
have a high estimate of one parameter it
might be low on the other so we
oftentimes so we so so we oftentimes you
hear people talk about cascading
uncertainty and it doesn't cascade as
many people think you know you add take
one uncertain variable and another and
another it doesn't just keep getting
wider in fact typically if they're not a
strong correlation once you take two and
you can add many more the uncertainty
really doesn't why not much more so this
combination of the uncertainty and
different things is really a critical
element that you don't get otherwise so
a couple of variables will give all the
full uncertainty unless they are really
minor but if can lead to the wrong
conclusions about what will reduce
uncertainty so if we just looked at one
or the other of these we'd say oh we can
reduce all the uncertainty by reducing
one but we'd be mistaken so that's the
reason to kind of understand these or so
thanks